I made $98,000 from one trade using
nothing but a simple candlestick pattern
that most traders overlook. In this
video, I'm going to break down the exact
strategy that completely changed my
trading, show you the live execution,
and more importantly, tell you what
causes most traders to lose money. My
name is Kyle, and after losing almost
everything trying to trade complex
systems, this one pattern helped me make
over $4 million in the past 3 years and
break the world record payout at Apex.
Let me show you exactly how it works.
All right. So, what is an engulfing bar?
Now, you guys have maybe heard me talk
about this before, but really, we only
are looking for two candles along with
context to be able to determine what is
an engulfing bar. So, let's just go in
here and we'll draw out the pattern.
Okay, so we have let's just assume that
we have this down candle. Okay, and
we'll draw an upper wick
and then a lower wick. So we have this
one specific candle. Now the following
candle, however,
right? What creates an engulfing bar.
Now this is exactly what it sounds like
is that the candle itself, right? And
we're just talking about the open, the
high, the low, and the close here. The
candlestick itself needs to take out the
previous candle's low as well as the
previous candle's high. So, what we're
looking for are both of these levels.
Now, let me just draw out a line here so
you guys can see exactly what I'm
talking about. So, we have this one down
closed candle, right? So, we have a down
candle and then the following candle,
right? This is our closure of that
previous candle. The following candle
will go lower, take out the previous low
and then turn around and take out the
previous high, maybe closing here. Now,
this two candle pattern gives us so much
information on where this next candle or
maybe the next couple candles are going
to go. Now, what is the context behind
all of this? Well, let's just draw it
out. So, we might have a candlestick
that opens here, right? Creates a high,
trades lower, and then closes here.
Okay? And this is just just assume that
this is our low time frame price action
here. So, I'll type low time frame.
Now, what creates the next engulfing
candle? This next engulfing candle opens
here, takes out what? The previous
candle's low. So, that's our swing low.
And then it turns around and takes out
the previous candle's high. Now, what
does this really give us as far as
context? Okay, we have here a liquidity
raid
and then here is our market structure
shift.
So within these two high time frame
candles, we have a lot of information
that's going on on the low time frames.
Okay, so we have this low time frame
structure. Okay, that creates this one
candle and let me just draw a line here
delineating the candles here. So this is
one candle. Just pretend that this is,
you know, maybe an hourly candle or a
daily candle. So inside of here, we're
going to have multiple what 5 minute, 15
minute or 1 minute candles that create
this one specific hour. Or let's say if
it's a day, we have 24 hourly candles.
Inside of this structure on the low time
frame, we might get this rate on
liquidity. We might get a shift in
delivery and then we get a market
structure shift. So all in all what does
this create?
This creates a market maker buy model.
So when we see these two candles form,
okay, these two candles alone are
showing us a market maker buy model on
the low time frame. Okay, because we
have the liquidity rate, we have the
smart money reversal inside of here.
Then we have some reaccumulation and
then we have a massive market structure
shift to the upside. So these two
candles alone may give us indication of
where that next candlestick is going to
go. Okay. Now when I'm trading when I
see these candles form and this is a
caveat is we need to be able to see a
closure. So we need to see a strong
closure on this second candle. And where
I used to mess up was I would think that
this would be an engulfing candle and
then by the end of the candlestick
closure, you know, it would kind of
close down here and it wouldn't be a
very strong candle closure. So, we're
looking for a large body to close, you
know, kind of towards the upper half,
you know, upper 50% of a specific candle
and kind of give us a nice large body
and vice versa. So, basically, we flip
this around for a bearish example. We
might have, you know, up close candle
here, right, that closes here. And then
on the next candle, we might go take out
buy side liquidity and then take out
sellside liquidity. So these two
scenarios, right? This here is just on a
lower time frame that creates a higher
time frame engulfing pattern. Okay? And
this creates what? Our market maker cell
model. Okay? So this is where you can
really use just two candlesticks on the
higher time frame to really give you the
context of what's going on on the low
time frame. All right. So now here's
what nobody really talks about is that
all these patterns, whether you're
trading a fair value gap, a market maker
model, engulfing bar patterns, they have
a failure rate. Now, I learned this the
hard way after blowing dozens of
accounts trying to trade every engulfing
bar pattern that I could find. So here
are two things that you really need to
take into account when you're trying to
trade these two candlestick patterns.
Number one, every setup has a failure
rate.
Now, if you go through and back test
these candlesticks, you will see that
some of them fail. Okay? Your your goal
as a trader is not to find something
that works 100% of the time because
there's a lot of traders out there that
think once they learn a setup that it's
never going to fail. And that is not
true. Every single pattern that you
learn and every single trade setup that
you have is going to have a failure
rate. So when I'm trading these
engulfing patterns, I rely on my context
and the overall narrative of the market
to avoid some of the failing trades, but
you need to understand this on a
personal level. So when you go through
and back test this specific trade setup
and when you're going through and
collecting your data, you might find out
that 60% of the time these trade
patterns do work, but the other 40% of
the time is where they fail. And if you
have proper risk management and money
management, trade management on the 40
or 50% of your winning trades, you
should be able to take advantage of
those market movements and really milk
them. And that way, your winners are
going to pay for your losers in the long
run, even if you lose on four or five or
six out of 10 trades. Now, another thing
that you need to take into account is
where these engulfing bars are forming.
And when I first started learning them,
I would just trade every single
engulfing bar. So, a way that I avoid
taking poor engulfing bar setups is if
I'm trying to be bullish, okay, let's
say if I'm bullish and the market is
trading higher, okay, if it forms above
a level of liquidity, so if the
engulfing bar forms here, I'm less
likely to trade it. What I actually want
to see if I'm bullish is I actually want
to see it form down here after taking
out liquidity. I actually want to see it
form down here at a swing low after
taking out sellside liquidity. So if it
forms up here after taking out buy side
liquidity, okay, these are really
indications that there might be
exhaustion. And usually when you see
engulfing bar patterns fail at a point
of exhaustion, it usually goes the other
direction. All right. So, number two,
avoid bullish
engulfing bars that appear after taking
out buy side liquidity. And vice versa,
avoid bearish
engulfing bars
that appear after taking out sellside
liquidity.
Okay? So, when you're looking for a
bearish engulfing candle, you want to
see it occur at a swing high. And if
you're looking for a bullish engulfing
bar pattern, you want to see it at a
swing low. Okay? So, using these as
filters is going to help you avoid a lot
of losing trades. And your strike rate
on these specific patterns should go up.
All right? So, now that you know what to
avoid, I'm going to show you the live
example from last week where I spotted
the perfect engulfing bar setup and
walked away with $98,000 in profit in
under 12 hours. But here's the thing.
What made this so profitable wasn't just
the pattern itself. It was the context
behind the trade idea and the trade
management. So let's walk through it all
together. All right. So you guys can see
here that we have this very large
bullish engulfing candle here. And this
actually occurred right after FOMC. So
FOMC this candle printed here. So after
FOMC, we can see that this candle closed
on the day and created a bullish
engulfing candle post FOMC. Now, as I
just talked about, we want to see these
occur at a swing low point, taking out
sellside liquidity, which is exactly
what we got. And not only that, where
we're trading inside of a daily fair
value gap. So, after we get this
engulfing bar pattern, I have a very
strong confidence that this market is
going to continue higher. Our first
target would be this buyside liquidity.
And because we're at all-time highs and
there's really nothing to the left of
our screen, I'm aiming for 25,000 whole
number as a psychological level to
approach all-time highs. So on a lower
time frame scale, okay, we've taken out
sellside liquidity, turned around and
taken out buy side liquidity as well. So
we've taken out this previous candle's
high and on a lower time frame. This is
our market maker buy model. So what
we're looking for after this candle
closure, right? And the closure is the
most important thing because let's say
if this candle uh took out the high and
then closed lower, that is not a bullish
engulfing candle. We're waiting for the
closure. So essentially, I enter this
trade as soon as the market rolled over
at 6 p.m. because this is futures. And I
just placed a 20 lot trade and my stop
loss is where it's at the weekly open
because I don't anticipate this market
trading lower down to this wick. That's
something that I would not want to see.
So I'm aiming for about a 1 to three
riskreward on this specific trade. Now
let's run through uh forward and just
drop down to the some of the lower time
frames. Okay, you guys can see here that
this is the lower time frame and just
like I mentioned when we get bearish
engulfing candles but taking out sell
side liquidity, this is really where I
avoid taking those trades. Okay, so this
bearish engulfing candle shows up at a
swing low point. And you guys can see
here the next the very next candle
trades higher. Okay, so when we lose
these engulfing candles, okay, it
typically just runs the other direction.
Okay, so when we got a breach of this
candle's high on a lower time frame,
right, we're expecting continuation from
that level to just continue trading
higher. And as the market's trading
higher, you guys can see that it's
creating bullish fair value gaps on the
way up, right? It's trading into this
bullish fair value gap. We have this
bullish fair value gap that I'm looking
at as this trade is moving in my favor.
So, just fast forwarding here.
You guys can see here that this is my
live account. I'll show you the live
login here.
Just so you know that this is not a demo
account. Okay, you can see that this is
my live balance. I have my account
number here, my account balance, and I'm
up floating 93K. Okay? And I don't want
you guys to focus on the amount of the
dollar amount because learning how to
trade these setups properly has nothing
to do with the size of trades that you
take. Okay? If you can take this trade
and make 200, $300, $400, it's really
just the amount of capital and the
amount of size that you can put behind
your trades. But I'm willing to take
that amount of risk because this is not
all of my liquidity. Okay? I have more
liquidity than just 200k. And I'm okay
risking 20, 30, $40,000 because it's
just a percentage of my liquid net
worth. Now, 5 10 years ago, I was not
comfortable trading this size. Okay? I
was comfortable maybe risking $500,
$1,000. And as my net worth grew, and as
my accounts grew, I'm more and more
comfortable taking larger amounts of
risk because from a percentage basis
standpoint, it's not that much.
Okay? So you guys can see here that this
is really just based off of that higher
time frame bullish engulfing candle
which is based on what the 4hour time
frame. So this 4hour candle is really
all I need. I don't really need to be on
the lower time frame. Okay. All I'm
looking for is this 4hour candle.
Everything else on the lower time frame
is just additional information that I
can use to either scale into my trades,
manage my stop losses, and see if this
market is going to continue pushing
towards my target.
Now, this market retraced on me a little
bit and there you go. There's the exit
right there.
So, kind of just to wrap things up, this
candlestick pattern is very easy to spot
in your charts. Now, as a homework
assignment, you guys should be going
through your charts, going through and
back testing and forward testing these
setups as they appear live. Where to put
your stop loss, how to position size
properly, how to trail your stop as the
market moves in your favor. So, let's
say if you entered here on a retracement
after we get this engulfing candle,
right? You entered on a retracement and
it pushes higher. How do I manage that
trade and scale into that position or
adjust my stop loss? Cuz maybe your stop
loss is down here originally, but as
it's going in your favor, as you guys
can see from here, I'm trying my best to
trail my stop up because I do not want
this market to come back and turn around
on me. So, as the market's moving in my
favor, maybe I have the ability to scale
in. Maybe I wanted to scale in around
here. Maybe I wanted to scale in here.
You know, there's so many different ways
that you can manage this trade, but it's
all based off of this one candlestick
pattern. If you want to see me trade
this exact strategy live and get direct
access to me and trade alongside someone
who has over 14 years of experience and
broke the world record payout, check out
the link in the description. I only work
with serious traders who are ready to
put in the work. So, if you're looking
for get-rich quick schemes, this isn't
for you. But if you're ready to learn
from someone who's actually made money
consistently in the markets, check out
the link in the description. With this
engulfing bar strategy and the rules I
just shared, you now have everything you
need to start identifying high
probability trading opportunities.
Remember, it's not about taking every
setup you see. It's about being
selective and following your rules
consistently. The difference between
profitable traders and everyone else
isn't talent or luck. It's discipline
and patience. So, thanks for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next